welcome to lab roots lab roots is a free
social networking site that enables
scientists engineers and other technical
professionals to connect and collaborate
with and learn from each other lab roots
provides fast access to news research
and trends along with information to
help you solve your problems lab roots
makes it easy to participate in dialogue
with other scientists once you set up
your lab roots homepage advanced data
mining technologies ensure that only
news and information relevant to your
interests are delivered to your home
page and with the lab roots site you can
easily search for jobs or share your
thoughts by creating a blog build your
network by joining a labyrinth group or
form a group of your own based on your
specific needs or interests finding
research relevant to your needs is easy
with the lab rats integrated
publications search system and as with
other lab roots features you can comment
on vote on and share your favorite
publications with others you can also
save key publications to your favorites
list for quick future reference
do you like or dislike an existing
product service technology or company
labret lets you write reviews to let
others know what you really think read
reviews from others before making a
purchase or when evaluating job
opportunities
lab roots knows that you are unique so
we have a variety of tools to meet your
needs you can personalize your space
placing only the tools you want on your
home page check in with labret lee as
new tools are always in development lab
roots makes it easy to connect
collaborate and learn here are a few
examples of how scientists are using lab
roots lab roots message board made it
easy for me to establish a collaboration
critical to my research identified a
professor who has the expertise and
facilities to assist me in my grant
application and related research I sent
him a message the next day he replied
and asked me to call him to discuss the
project
I was having problems with one of my
experiments I asked for advice on
elaborate scheme on a form and I've
already received three responses I'm
going to rerun my experiment
incorporating the suggestions right now
getting started with leverage is easy
join labrys today